foreign
good afternoon everyone
my name is Dr Miller and the SCP we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-4006
object class
meal
special containment procedures no
concrete containment procedures are
necessary actions taken in regards to
scp-4006 should follow standard protocol
of maintaining the veil protocol MTV
description
scp-406 is a probabilistic anomaly
affecting the state of Massachusetts
United States of America
scp-406 Works to perpetuate the idea
that Massachusetts is a populated state
with a government infrastructure economy
various population centers Etc due to
this the true nature of Massachusetts is
entirely unknown to the public
Massachusetts has no history of human
occupation
all effects of scp-406 are in and of
themselves mundane events though highly
improbable it is the pervasiveness and
frequency of these night incalculably
low probability events and their
collaboration to effectively spread
misinformation about Massachusetts that
earns scp-406 anomalous recognition
why several SCP Foundation researchers
were immune to the effects of scp-4006
and were able to discover it and
subsequently spread the information to
others is unclear to better understand
scp-406's effect the following is a
heavily Abridged early history of
Massachusetts
Massachusetts lacks any tribal presence
several Nations including Britain
Portugal Spain and France begin to
colonize the new world or the Americas
Britain knowing of France's plans to
claim the northernmost parts of North
America Claims to have a colony further
north in Jamestown and names the full
Colony Plymouth
due to poor communication further
colonists are led to believe that the
land of Massachusetts has already been
colonized colonists that wish to go to
Plymouth and explicably find themselves
Landing further south after terrible
ocean storms such colonists are met with
other colonists who believe themselves
to be further north and call the area
Massachusetts
the fishing industry operates out of
Rhode Island though fishing boats are
pushed North by Southern winds to the
coast of Massachusetts no boats ever
land on the beaches and no human steps
foot onto any land in Massachusetts
Rhode Island and Connecticut develop
unknowing of the presence of people
believing to be within Massachusetts
colonies use the same land and harvest
from the same forests but never come
into direct contact with one another
colonists believing to be from
Massachusetts Hereafter referred to as
scp-4006-a and colonists from
Connecticut and Rhode Island finally
meet but never explicitly discuss their
location
scp-4006-a assumed the others they meet
to also believe themselves to be for
Massachusetts
cities established two or more separate
governments and assume separate names
people believing themselves to be from
one city or another only meet with
police forces and only read of the news
pertaining to the City Identity they
believe to be true the governments of
each City never become aware of each
other's existence and continue to
function independently
the same pattern is established as the
colonies of Rhode Island and Connecticut
establish government while
scp-4006a believed these governments to
be their own governments English
surveillance of each colony is tricked
in much the same way and correctly
assuming they have crossed the border
into Massachusetts and only then
encountering
scp-4006-a when discussing Regional
affairs
it is difficult to assess the history of
Massachusetts past this due to scp-406's
effect by 1928
scp-4006-a spanned the entire east coast
and several Northeastern states
concentrations were and are still
highest in Rhode Island Connecticut New
Hampshire Vermont New York and New
Jersey the furthest west that scp-4006a
have been identified is North Dakota
people believing themselves to be
visiting any city in Massachusetts such
as Boston will actually be in any number
of other cities near Massachusetts such
cities include New York City
Philadelphia Buffalo and Pittsburgh
whenever in a conversation where the
name of trivia about or landmarks within
the city are discussed people will only
encounter others who believe themselves
to be in the same city
note that due to the scale of scp-4006
only enough effects to communicate the
nature of scp-406 have been recorded
here for a list of all recorded effects
of scp-4006 contact any Personnel of
level 4 4006 clearance
addendum 4806 1. Foundation occupation
of Massachusetts
scp-406's effects make Massachusetts an
unusually secure location for foundation
activities however while scp-406 is
currently the most powerful probability
based anomaly within the foundation's
knowledge purview and containment it has
been shown to be imperfect as several
Foundation scientists were able to
discover the true nature of
Massachusetts while researching
anomalies they believed to be within
Massachusetts as such protocol MTV 4006
has been created protocol MTV 4006 is a
reminder to all involved with scp-4006
and those working in sites within
Massachusetts
will keep activity secret continue to
take all necessary precautions to
maintain the veil in the event that
scp-4006 fails to censor all information
about the true nature of Massachusetts
in the name of MTV 4006 the foundation
has allocated several million USD a year
towards creating further defenses
against the public discovery of the true
nature of Massachusetts such precautions
have included
setting up sites at the locations of
several supposed cities Boston
Springfield Etc and making the sites
appear to satellites like normal
buildings
having roads between sites mimic the
publicly agreed upon road maps of
Massachusetts for example the sites
between Springfield and Boston use a
connecting road that is technically a
continuation of Highway 90 and wearing
mostly civilian style clothing while
wandering outside of sites
at the time of writing all precautions
have been wholly unnecessary as scp-4006
continues to function as expected this
fact has not diminished the foundation's
dedication to protocol mtv4006
addendum 4006 1 extension continued
Foundation occupation of Massachusetts
sites within Massachusetts have expanded
to be the five largest Foundation sites
site 19s function as the largest
collection of foundation level 5
Personnel site surveyors hmcl
supervisors Etc as well as the home of
the Ethics Committee board has now been
transferred to site 4006 based at the
supposed location of Boston many
difficult to contain SCP objects or
objects that take up a significant
amount of space to contain have since
been moved on mass to Massachusetts
hundreds of foundation researchers staff
and miscellaneous Personnel have been
migrated to Massachusetts in consequence
in light of this several developments
have been made in the name of protocol
mtv4006 including
an airport has been created by site 4006
in mimicry of the supposed Logan
International Airport where private
Foundation airplanes disguised as
commercial flights may make it easier to
commute to and from Massachusetts plans
to create airports in several other
locations in Massachusetts have been
drafted
infrastructure mimicking real cities has
been implemented to create Easy Living
For Those within Massachusetts all
businesses have been placed in locations
mimicking online maps of the Cities
a more complex roadway system across
Massachusetts to make for easier commute
between sites and testing locations
in response to these developments
project
4006-109 full realization of
Massachusetts has been proposed in hopes
of creating a functioning state within
the United States in which the
foundation alone may operate and
accommodate for thousands of personnel
official implementation of project
4006-109 would begin in two years if
approved
addendum 40062 completion of project
4006-109 and expanding awareness of
scp-4006
project 4006-109 has been completed and
the state of Massachusetts recreated
from common public misunderstandings of
its structure all major cities and small
towns have been created infrastructure
mimicked housing populated with SCP
Foundation personnel and all major
public roads created the US government
has begun to treat the physical location
of Massachusetts and its foundation
personnel as true citizens of
Massachusetts SCP Foundation personnel
and the U.S government have implemented
a system by which only fellow Foundation
Personnel within the government ever
preside over Massachusetts this way the
true nature of Massachusetts continues
to remain secret while also allowing the
SCP foundation's Recreation of
Massachusetts to function as a real
state within the United States
commercial flights have now been seen
flying over Massachusetts and several
civilian cars have passed through
Massachusetts at various times in light
of this classified Foundation activities
have been further suppressed and
protocol MTV 4006 has taken even higher
precedence testing areas above ground
have been officially closed off to the
public to make certain that civilians
passing through do not stumble upon
classified materials
several addenda have been removed due to
redundancy and repetition to view a full
list of removed agenda contact any
researcher of level 4 4006 clearance
addendo 4006 8 uncertainty regarding
scp-4006
in 2023 it has been found that fewer
than 20 people believing themselves to
be in Massachusetts exist outside of the
state of Massachusetts and that those
that do are not under the effects of a
probabilistic anomaly such as scp-4006
Massachusetts is now more populated by
normal U.S citizens than Foundation
Personnel while Massachusetts Remains
the largest collection of SCP Foundation
assets all Sites testing grounds
outposts and otherwise are hidden and
contained in light of this three motions
have been proposed
reclassify scp-4006 is neutralized
reclassify scp-406 as explained
and keep scp-406 as thamu the first
motion argues that scp-4006 no longer
quantifiably exists the second motion
argues that while scp-4006 was a large
enough phenomenon to Warrant the
designation of an SCP object at the time
every individual piece of scp-4006 was
able to be explained by coincidence and
science
the third motion has been put forth by
the o5 council
level 5 406 clearance required
item number scp-4006
object class thumbhill
special containment procedures
non-applicable
description
scp-4006's existence is in and of itself
theoretical proof of scp-4006's
existence or non-existence is not being
concretely gathered but due to
scp-4006's likelihood to exist and its
position as the most powerful
probabilistic anomaly in existence if it
were to exist it has been recorded as an
SCP object
evidence for scp-406's existence
includes the Public's ignorance of the
true nature of Massachusetts
The public's ignorance of the true
nature of the universe
the containment of over 3 000 SCP
objects with breaches and secrecy being
only temporary
the existence of scp-2000 and other
thalmia SCP objects
the existence of scp-3000 and the
discovery of amnestic compounds in
general at convenient times in the
foundation's history Earth's dimensions
being particularly disconnected and
difficult to access from the rest of the
Multiverse
the non-existence of any powerful groups
whose goals include the complete
destruction of normalcy
the existence of several powerful groups
whose goals include the maintenance of
normalcy
the existence of the SCP Foundation
however due to scp-406 only potentially
existing and evidence suggesting that if
it does exist that the SCP Foundation in
part perpetuates it it is best to assume
that scp-4006 does not exist allowing
the theory of scp-4006's existence to
perpetuate May instill a sense of apathy
and meaninglessness leading towards SCP
Foundation Personnel taking far greater
risks than are necessary while holding
the belief that scp-4006 will cover any
mistakes of theirs
scp-4006 is the phenomenon known as the
Veil
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are
and you are all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to
big sip
zargaron
oh crap guy
James Saba
braided Peach
that loser
Richard broadhurst
fire of prime
Dr Wolf 13.
copster
worthy fire
zazapan
Irish wristwatch
segnore
a la trayon
your local Foundation agent
and Lost Boy
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you